and everybody will gather together and
eat really delicious food and have a
great time
hi I'm Edie today I'll show you how to
make Chinese dumplings Doutzen so in
Chinese homes dumplings are a
traditional must have food on New Year's
Eve families wrap them up and eat them
as the clock strikes at midnight the
finished dumpling dough texture should
be soft but not too wet resting the
dough can make the dough feels really
smooth and soft so it makes kneading
process easier later I think adding
ground citron pepper is a secret
ingredients I've learned from my mom
making dumplings if you taste it by
itself it gives you a little numbing on
the tongue however when you put it in
the stuffing it will give you depth and
flavor my personal twist to the recipe
is adding shrimp to it adding shrimps to
the recipe provides you a more
refreshing flavor and I hope other
people can enjoy it as well I remember
when I was a kid on Chinese New Year Eve
my entire family a full house of people
they will stand together and make the
dumplings and my mom will always save
the extra dough for me and my little
cousin we won't just play with it for
the night shaping the dough into a
doughnut shape helps you to get a even
rope out of the dough so later when you
apportion it you can get a nice even
smaller portions out of it as well so I
think that's a cool trip from my mom
when you're apportioning dough that's
also another trick I learned from just
watching how my family does it
the turning technique will help you get
a nearly more perfect ball when you try
to ball it up later eating dumplings
reminds me of making it with my parents
and my extended family on all different
occasions it could be a weekend dinner
or Chinese New Year since now I'm away
from home I live abroad whenever I eat
dumplings I think about my family member
and how they're doing a younger me
before I left home I wasn't super into
dumplings at all but when I moved away
from home when I was in Chicago living
with my roommate we wouldn't make
dumplings sometimes because it makes me
feel homey and it's a remedy for
homesick it's always been about family
and food
hi I'm Holly and today I'll be showing
you how to make kingi or a wholesome
fish so this fish is just traditionally
served during Chinese New Year dinner it
represents a good year from start to
finish
and in this case head to tail U is also
sounds like prosperity in Chinese so
that's why we eat it so this recipe is
very important to me because I've been
eating it basically all throughout my
life my grandma or mom would cook it for
dinner
almost every day of the week at least
three to four times a week and it just
reminds me of my childhood
so the flavor is just a good balance of
salty and savory and just that mommy
flavor that a lot of Asian dishes have
from majority of China they would eat it
similar way today we use red snapper but
you can totally use tilapia or sea bass
my mom usually uses live whole fish so a
good trick to know when the fish is done
is to poke the thickest part of the fish
that's where you'll know you in tested
to see if it's cooked all the way
through or if you need a little bit more
time for it to cook what I'm most proud
of having both cultures is definitely
the food and the variety of dishes that
I'm able to try ever since I was young I
love my hamburgers and pizza but having
different cultures in my background is
also it's amazing in itself Chinese New
Year is just a celebration of the start
of a new year in the Chinese calendar
similar to American New Year is just a
nice way to refresh the year I've been
celebrating Lunar New Year since I was
young how we celebrated is eating a
large family dinner with my uncles and
my aunts and my parents and my
grandparents just everyone gathering
around the table
oh yes
jinyoung koala Judea to Antioch Waialua
Shinyoung hello